hätte er heute live herzlich willkommen
morgen startet eine wichtige mission
nicht zum mond nicht zum mars sondern
nach doha der auftrag der
weltgesundheitsorganisation whu
herausfinden wo das corona virus her
kommt ein internationales forscherteam
macht sich auf die suche nach dem
ursprung der pandemien ihre reise
beginnt in china wo hahn und dort wollen
sie herausfinden stammt das krone virus
wirklich von fledermäusen das gilt als
wahrscheinlich aber welches tier
fungiert als zwischenwirt als stiller
überträger die antworten könnten die
wissenschaftler aus wo herausführen zum
ausgangspunkt der pandemie nach südchina
oder gar nach europa die wissenschaftler
wollen laborergebnisse sichten studien
überprüfen auch solche die darauf
hinweisen dass das virus schon im
november vergangenen jahres nachgewiesen
wurde
oder früher am ende der reise steht vor
allem diese frage woher stammt patient
null
der erste mensch der sich mit dem corona
virus infizierte tja und einer der
eigentlich bei dieser mission dabei sein
sollte jetzt aber hier bei uns in
zugeschaltet ist ist doktor fabian lenz
vom robert-koch-institut er ist tierarzt
epidemiologe und einer der weltweit
besten erforscher von zoonosen also von
infektionskrankheiten die von tieren auf
den menschen übertragbar sind und wieder
zurück herr dr
nun können sie kurzfristig aus privaten
gründen nicht bei dieser mission dabei
sein
wie schmerzhaft ist das für sie als
wissenschaftler ja das war für mich
natürlich extrem schmerzhaft war ich
mich sehr gefreut habe
bei diesem team dabei zu sein und bei
dieser ersten mission
aber das was mich dann wieder so ruhig
ist dass es noch mehrere missionen geben
und das setzte wirklich erst der anfang
gemacht wird und so bin ich jetzt total
kann man ja auch online bei den
besprechungen und so weiter dabei seien
also werde mich da einbringen durch
heben kann
wir haben gerade gehört dass die frage
wer patient null ist viele interessiert
ich kann mir aber auch vorstellen dass
das bei der suche nach einem ursprung
eines virus das bei vielen menschen
überhaupt keine symptome hervorruft eine
schwierige sache sein wird glauben sie
dass man diesen patienten null denn
überhaupt finden wird in der
klassischerweise wäre das der
optimalfall dass man die infect kette
sozusagen dies kontakt racing was hier
in ganz deutschland in der welt momentan
gemacht wird in der zeit rückwärts macht
und dann eben bei den patienten los
außerdem hierher sich bei irgendeinem
tier angesteckt hat eben findet das ist
einfacher weil viren wie zum beispiel wo
lavieren wo man ganz eindeutige symptome
zeigt man hat fieber und blutigen
durchfall und so weiter bei diesem coup
19 erkrankungen wie wir ja leider alle
wissen gibt es leider eben auch ganz
viele fälle die bild infiziert sind oder
gar keine symptome zeigen und da ist es
natürlich wesentlich schwieriger allein
durch das befragen der leute in der zeit
zurück zu gehen das heißt da brauchen
sie ein paar mehr ansetzen und war
innovative ansätze um zu versuchen
möglichst einzuengen wo so ungefähr sind
wir jetzt am anfang dieser großen im
parkett wir schauen gleich was die
kollegen vor ort recherchieren können wo
sie ansetzen wo sie versuchen können
etwas herauszufinden nun unterscheidet
diese aktuelle suche nach dem sauerstoff
2 virus sich ziemlich von dem was sie
eigentlich sonst machen ihr team am
robert-koch-institut umfasst ja viele
disziplinen und sie sind vor allem in
afrika unterwegs südlich der sahara auf
der suche nach neuen killerviren
sozusagen
sie haben uns ein paar bilder geschickt
die zeigen wie sie vor ort arbeiten
die können wir uns gemeinsam anschauen
und ich würde sie bitten uns ein
bisschen zu erklären wie ihre
eigentliche arbeit und die ihres teams
normalerweise aussieht
hier sehen wir es da sind sie unterwegs
ich mutmaße in der elfenbeinküste an der
elfenbeinküste richtig genau diese
aufnahmen stammen kein nationalpark an
der elfenbeinküste
und dort haben wir ein langzeitprojekt
wo wir wild lebenden primaten waren die
menschenaffen also hier diesem angabe
war aber auch vor allem schimpansen die
menschen auch dafür nutzen quasi als
indikatoren als frühwarnsystem für neue
krankheitserreger die für uns relevant
sein könnten eben zu identifizieren
wenn wir dann so ein erreger gefunden
haben dann schauen wir nach der
möglichen quelle sehr ähnlich wie das
was jetzt in china passieren wird und da
ist dann die frage was ist zum beispiel
die rolle von fledermäusen hier sieht
man jetzt ein flughund art die wir da
gefangen haben die kriegen da ein
rachenabstrich unangenehmen wie wir das
ja auch alle inzwischen wissen aber die
tiere werden alle nicht invasiv
beprobten dann wieder freigelassen und
dann können wir jetzt entsprechenden
proben eben untersuchen wir haben
gesehen tragen schutzanzüge die wir
jetzt doch aus diesen berichten über die
pandemie hier nur allzu gut kennen wie
gefährlich ist denn diese arbeit vor ort
ich denke wenn man weiß dass man sich
schützen muss und wie dann ist es
wesentlich ungefährlicher als jetzt
taxifahren in berlin oder so etwas also
da das darf man nicht zu sehr sensation
analysieren wir haben das alle gelernt
wie das geht und machen das ordentlich
und dass das ist kein keine sorgen
warum ist diese arbeit vor ort so
wichtig welche erkenntnisse gewinnen die
daraus es ist wichtig zu verstehen wie
zu losen auf den menschen überspringen
also die verschiedenen viren aber auch
bakterien weil nur wenn man das problem
erkannt kann man erkennt kann man sich
auch überlegen was mache ich jetzt
dagegen gibt es irgendwelche
verhaltensweisen bei menschen die wir
ändern können gibt es bestimmte
gegebenheiten die man vermeiden sollte
so etwas wie zum beispiel intensive
tierzucht die noch zugänglich ist zu
wild tierbeständen so dass zwischen
wildtieren und nutztieren kontakte
bestehen können
großes thema die jagd nach wild fleisch
dem sogenannten bushmeat liefe davon ist
wirklich notwendig für die lokale
bevölkerung und wieviel könnte man
eigentlich sein lassen weil es nur für
die luxus konsum in den städten ist und
so weiter aber man braucht solide daten
um dann zu sagen das sind
vielversprechende punkte wo wir ansetzen
um das risiko des auftretens von
pandemien zu reduzieren 100 prozent
ausschließen werden es leider nie können
wie immer in dieser sendung herr dr
leben als bitten wir unsere user sich zu
beteiligen fragen zu stellen das tun wir
an dieser stelle explizit nochmal bitte
eure fragen in die kommentare oder wenn
er oder sie die zdf- heute- app nutzt
bitte an diese hier eingeblendete
e-mail-adresse und über youtube kommt
hier schon eine frage von einem user
namens radfahrer ohne motor was muss
passieren damit es zu einer zoonose
kommt eine änderung in der m rna wenn ja
welche fragezeichen naja es damit es zu
zu lösen kommen zudem über sprung eines
erregers von einem tier auf den menschen
oder auch andersrum brauchen wir
verschiedenste faktoren das ist wirklich
ein relativ komplexes gebilde und eine
relativ lange kette an ereignissen wir
brauchen also den kontakt zwischen dem
tier und dem menschen in diesem fall
dann musste der neue erreger ist
schaffen sich in dem neuen hör zu
etablieren in die menschen er muss sich
andocken können irgendwo gerade bei den
viren die können sich ja nicht selbst
multiplizieren wir brauchen ja unsere
zellen um sich zu vermehren
das heißt das müssen sie erstmal
hinkriegen diesen neuen organismus dazu
überreden selbst welche herzustellen
mehr viren herzustellen und dann muss
das arme tier was natürlich dauernd auch
bekämpft wird von unserem immunsystem
auch noch an eine stelle kommen wo es
dann auch den menschen auf den nächsten
menschen übertragbar ist also war das
gerät origin wir natürlich in die
atemwege ist eine relativ gute
übertragung methode quasi gibt aber auch
sexuell übertragbare erkrankung wenn man
zum beispiel an das hiv denkt was vom
schimpansen stammt auch über diese
bushmeat jagd
übergesprungen ist also das ist jetzt
nicht nur dass man das auch in einer m
rna und so weiter zurückführen kann da
sind ganz ganz viele faktoren
und jede dieser faktoren ab zum glück
ihre stärken und deswegen sehen wir
dafür dass wir so viel kontakt zu tieren
haben insgesamt gesehen doch relativ
selten zu lösen wenn wir diese idee dann
ist es eine katastrophe auf der
katastrophe die wir gerade erleben aber
diese barrieren funktioniert prinzipiell
ziemlich gut dann schauen wir mal auf
diese katastrophe die wir gerade erleben
und schauen uns die arbeit die da
bevorsteht ingo hahn an welche
forschungsergebnisse erhoffen sie sich
und ich hatte eine frage genau die ich
gerne an sie weitergeben wollte von
sebastian fischer auch über youtube wo
vermutet man zurzeit den ursprung
das problem bei dieser pandemie ist
wirklich dass die daten zu einem
möglichen ursprung noch extrem schwach
sind und deswegen hat die wehr auch
diese internationale expertinnen und
experten zusammen gerufen um dann
zusammen mit den chinesischen
kolleginnen und kollegen die haben wir
exzellente wissenschaftler auch in china
dass wir zusammen überlegen was gibt es
an daten und wo sind noch die lücken um
dieses puzzle so zu machen dass man ein
bild erkennen kann
und das heißt das was wir bisher wissen
ist wirklich marginal wir wissen dass
das nächste avant aber nicht der
ursprung dieses virus was uns menschen
heimsucht bei einer fledermaus art im
südlichen china gefunden wurde
das heißt aber die absolut nicht das ist
jetzt unbedingt der nächste verwandte
dieser fledermaus im südlichen china
sein muss das alles muss weiter
untersucht werden und dafür macht das
expertenteam eben hatte einen plan bei
dieser ersten mission
das heißt aber wo haben es quasi nur der
ausgangspunkt geht man ist nicht
irgendwo hin weil man sagt es kommt vom
dar sondern wohin ist eben der ort wo es
zum ersten mal am menschen festgestellt
wurde stand jetzt da gibt es auch wieder
unterschiedliche meinungen dazu kann man
vielleicht gleich nochmal dazu kommen
aber aufgrund der datenlage ist am
wahrscheinlichsten dass es sinn macht
info
hans zu suchen was aber nicht heißt dass
einen die reise möglicherweise nach
südchina oder ganz woanders hinziehen
wird
ja genau das ist richtig wir fangen in
doha man weil dort immer noch die
solideste ersten fall beschreibung
vorliegen ja und auch dieses erste event
dieser markt in wo hahn über den sehr
viel berichtet wurde
da ist ja die frage haben die menschen
denen schon kontaminiert mit dem virus
so dass man ihn dort eben nachweisen
konnte
oder ist auf diesen markt tatsächlich
das virus von tier auf mensch
übergesprungen das wissen ja alles noch
nicht aber wir fangen da an wo wir die
besten spuren haben das ist was
eigentlich jeder jäger das macht aber
die besten spuren sind und dann folgen
wir den spuren zurück in der zeit und da
müssen wir verschiedene ansätze
verfolgen weil wir schon einen ganz
sagten es eben nicht leicht sein wird
das einzugrenzen ja das heißt wir fangen
bei den menschen an
gucken gibt es zum beispiel proben daten
von den letzten monaten in 20 19
die uns da hilfreich sein können fangen
auch der tier seite anschauen gibt es
irgendwelche daten zu welche tiere
wurden auf dem markt ingo hanke handelt
und wo kommen die her und so weiter also
da müssen wir verschiedenste blickwinkel
einnehmen um hoffentlich dann zu einer
guten szenario zu kommen es gibt eine
sichtweise denn ich das jetzt mal die
unter anderem auch der amerikanische
präsident
donald trump vertreten hat und auch mike
pompey das geäußert hat nämlich die
theorie oder die idee dass das virus
nicht tierischen ursprungs ist sondern
aus einem labor in wo hahn stammt und
dazu fragt der user t-punkt als auch
über youtube werden die experten zugang
zu den mysteriösen biolabor in johann
erhalten teilweise und jetzt ist es weg
aber das ist die sr da ist es wieder
teilweise gibt es die vermutung es sei
eventuell aus diesem labor wenn ich mich
richtig erinnere
danke können sie darauf ein bisschen
eingehen also zum einen die frage gibt
es auch zutritt für die experten in
dieses labor und zum anderen für wie
wahrscheinlich halten sie das dass das
virus eben nicht tierischen ursprungs
ist sondern aus einem labor kommt also
wir gehen an diese untersuchung rein
wissenschaftlich dran und da sollte man
nicht im vorhinein ausschließen
wir sind uns aber eigentlich und die
meisten experten weltweit dass es extrem
unwahrscheinlich ist dass es aus diesem
labor entkommen ist das virus einfach
wenn man sich überlegt wie häufig
passieren unfälle und wie intensiv
unglaublich intensiv ist der kontakt
zwischen mensch und tier gerade in china
werden ja alle möglichen arten von
tieren auch gegessen was wir uns gar
nicht so richtig vorstellen können
es gibt viele farmen von tierarten die
auch hier selten gehalten werden wo man
sich auch vorstellen kann dass es da
kontakte wiederum zu sein ist nun
fledermäuse oder andere reservat ihre
gibt also deswegen das ist nicht von der
liste der möglichen hypothesen runter
erhalten dass wir unglaublich
unwahrscheinlich sollten uns jetzt aber
die wissenschaftlichen daten in richtung
von einem labor muss unbedingt diese
seien führen dann werden wir auch diese
spuren folgen kann man denn aus dem
virus herauslesen aus der sequenz des
virus herauslesen ob es menschen gemacht
ist oder ob es tierischen ursprungs ist
und damit die frage relativ schnell und
leicht beantworten oder würden sie sagen
nee da lohnt es sich tatsächlich auch
für diese expertengruppe noch mal
genauer hin zu kommen dann muss man auf
jeden fall genauer hingucken dass man
wir auch da gibt es verschiedene
hypothesen die da zu korrigieren aber
also das was da bis jetzt spekuliert
wurde ist nicht besonders solide im
augenblick gehen wir davon aus dass er
es mit einem natürlichen virus zu tun
haben sie müssen sich vorstellen auch in
der freien natur werden können sich re
kombinieren das heißt die mission ihr
genom wenn sie dann in irgendeinem
zwischen 14 zum beispiel oder arten in
kontakt kommen die sonst nicht
miteinander in kontakt kommen und gerade
bei unserem eindringen in die natur und
den turbulenzen die wir leider in den
ökosystemen verursachen ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit solcher ereignisse
jetzt natürlich auch nochmal gestiegen
das heißt wir schauen uns das an gegeben
wie gesagt mit einem offenen blick dran
aber das ist überhaupt nicht jetzt die
haupt wurde die heißeste spur jörg pohl
ich würde gern zu dem offenen blick noch
eine kleine kurve in die politische
dimension unternehmen denn viele sagen
würden die chinesen überhaupt zulassen
dass man dort alle quellen einsehen kann
alles recherchieren kann was aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht interessant
wäre mentees jeder fragt über facebook
warum wurde so lange gewartet bis nach
forschungen gemacht wurden und nordlicht
84 fragt über youtube als ob das whu dem
info hand frei arbeiten darf sobald die
was finden wir denen das doch gleich
abgenommen
wie läuft die zusammenarbeit und wie
frei sind sie da in ihren recherchen
ja es ist also prinzipiell wir
expertinnen und experten sind in dem
team für unsere technische expertise mit
unserem know-how versuchen wir eben
diese diese spuren vielen spuren zu
folgen wie gesagt meine erfahrung ist
jetzt ist dass die diskussion die wir
bis jetzt online hatten mit unseren
chinesischen kolleginnen und kollegen
sehr gut und sehr offenbar und ich
möchte darauf hinweisen dass auch die
chinesische seite das interesse haben
könnte solide da zu generieren was nun
passiert ist um diese gerüchte ganz
loswerden wird man sie nicht weil es
immer leute gibt die an seltsame dinge
glauben aber am wenigsten zu sagen nein
die wahrscheinlichste hypothese ist
dieses um diese szene
also und da gibt's ja auch schon
verschiedene statements von den
chinesischen behörden dass wir dort
willkommen sind sonst würden wir gar
nicht dahin reisen können dass sie
großes interesse haben und das hören wir
auch aus der community vor ort also ich
würde da jetzt erst mal nicht mit so
voreingenommen herangehen sollte ich
irgendwann enttäuscht sein dann können
wir ja noch mal darüber reden aber im
augenblick bin ich eigentlich sehr
positiv eingestellt erlebt man ja auch
dass die chinesische regierung durchaus
ein interesse daran hat festzustellen
oder zu behaupten oder zu mutmaßen dass
es das virus schon vor dezember 2009 10
an anderen stellen der welt gegeben hat
und immer wieder haben auch forscher
berichtet dass die antikörper gefunden
haben aus italien zum beispiel aus dem
elsass gab es berichte von symptomen die
darauf hinweisen könnten
das saas kauf zwei schon viel früher
gegeben hat was ist denn zu diesen
einschätzungen aus ihrer sicht zu sagen
also diese ganzen berichte haben wir
natürlich im auge und auf dem plan
keiner dieser berichte war bis jetzt so
solide dass wir gesagt haben wir fangen
jetzt in italien mit der suche an und
doch nicht in doha
ja da war jeder dieser studien gibt es
signifikante schwachpunkte gerade diese
antikörper studien da weiß man ja dass
es das oft falsch positive gibt
kreuzreaktion mit ähnlichen viren und so
weiter also drei theologen muss man sehr
aufpassen und bei dem was genau passiert
ist da braucht man mindestens dann das
folgende und das müsste dann auch in
dieser abfolge der sequenzen die wir
jetzt haben wir wissen dass wir uns
entwickelt sich dauernd weiter das heißt
man kann auch zurück zur urgroßmutter
dieser ganzen ihren klaren sie kommen
und da müsste dann ja diese sequenz auch
vernünftig hinfallen und ich habe jetzt
noch keinerlei soliden daten gesehen
auch auf genomischer ebene die das
untermauern würden aber wir schließen
das nicht aus wir erhalten das im blick
und gucken wenn die spur und dann von wo
haben in die lombardei
führt dann vielleicht landen da sogar in
berlin ich bin mir ganz auf die reise
ist noch lange nicht zu ende
dann blicken wir mal kurz zurück denn
diese epidemie diese pandemie ist nicht
die erste zu hause mit der die
menschheit und auch die tiere und die
umwelt zu kämpfen haben nina niebergall
fast für uns mal zusammen wie gefährlich
solche zu losen sein können und welche
ist in der vergangenheit auch schon
gegeben hat krankheiten die von tieren
auf menschen übertragen werden gibt es
immer häufiger davor warnen
wissenschaftler schon seit jahren
mindestens 70% menschlicher
infektionskrankheiten sind zu losen
übertragen von nutztieren etwa die
schweinegrippe märz front rommé darin
aber vor allem von wildtieren hiv stammt
vermutlich von schimpansen ebola von
fledermäusen
der grund wir kommen den tieren zu nah
zerstören ihren lebensraum im
minuten-takt ein gefährlicher
zusammenhang wie im letzten jahr auch
die bundesumweltministerin feststellte
je mehr der mensch die natur zerstört
desto größer ist das risiko dass der
virus überspringt und desto größer ist
das risiko eines krankheitsausbruchs bis
hin eben zu einer pandemie
ein beispiel die herstellung von palmöl
plantagen anzulegen hat indonesien drei
viertel seiner wälder gerodet vertreibt
damit auch fledermäuse die lassen sich
in malaysia auf obstbäume nieder und
bringen das gefährliche virus mit etwa
die hälfte der infizierten stirbt
berlin hat immer wieder die fledermaus
auf youtube fragt david was macht
bestimmte tiere wie fledermäuse zu guten
viren überträgern gibt es auch tierarten
in deutschland die gute wären überträger
sind die fledermäuse tauchen relativ
häufig auch aber in dem beispiel was
gerade gezeigt wurde wird ja auch
gezeigt wie wichtig die rolle der
nutztiere ist
dass das hiv was ja wirklich noch eine
große geißel unserer menschheit ist vom
schimpansen abstand und so weiter die
kläger mäuse sind eine unglaublich
artenreiche gattung und pro art hat
jeder auch wir menschen trägt zu sein
sein spektrum an ihren mit sich herum
und da es eben viele arten gibt es gibt
auch viele verschiedene viren in diesen
tieren
außerdem haben sie die eigenschaft
mancher art in großen kolonien zu leben
was natürlich für so ein virus auch nett
ist weil es sich dann von tier zu tier
leichter verbreiten kann als wenn jetzt
so eine fledermaus allein irgendwo im
baum hängt dann weiß dass wir uns ja gar
nicht wohin mit mir
und dann gibt's noch bestimmte
immunologische faktoren die viel
diskutiert werden dass sie besonders
resistent sind manchen sehr gefährlichen
keimen gegenüber wie zum beispiel also
deswegen sind das schon ein da ist es
eine interessante richtung zuschauen
aber man sollte auch nicht vergessen
dass es auch andere sachen geben könnte
die eigenschaft um fledermäuse und
flughunde nun auch noch eine rolle
spielen ist auch dass einige von ihnen
zur kultur folgern geworden ist was
tolles weil sonst würden wahrscheinlich
aussterben und um unsere behausung
drumherum leben das ist eine sehr sehr
wichtige sache
das darf man auf keinen fall verteufeln
sondern sie haben eine unglaubliche
bedeutung in unserem lokal luckow system
sie fressen uns die kassen müssen weg
womit man sich sonst andere krankheiten
holen würde also der benefit fledermaus
und sich drum herum zu haben selig
größer als die gefahr andere kläger also
fleder tierarten zu denen gehört auch
die flughunde dann sind so groß dass es
auch wert sind gegessen zu werden gerade
dort wo ich viel arbeit in zentral- und
westafrika stehen die durchaus auch auf
dem speiseplan
und zwar immer mehr je mehr von den
großen tierarten aus gejagt werden
einfach aussterben regional desto mehr
fahren die leute auch an die kleineren
tiere zu essen die haben auch noch da
sind und da kommen immer mehr
fledermäuse flughunde aber auch große
namen
tiere große rappen arten auf den
speiseplan und das sind tiere die die
natürliche potenzial haben bestimmte
politische erreger zu tragen wenn wir
uns anschauen auch das wurde ja gerade
im beitrag angesprochen welche rolle wir
alle spielen unser verhalten unser
konsumverhalten hier hat auch eine
auswirkung darauf wie in den wäldern
südamerikas oder auch in den dörfern
afrikas gelebt und gewirtschaftet wird
jetzt fragt selina süße über youtube
glauben sie dass es in zukunft vermehrt
passieren wird dass viren aus dem
tierreich auf den menschen übertragen
werden
ich befürchte das wird so sein wobei
wenn man sich das genau betracht die
frage der übertragung
früher gab es mehr leute noch die die im
ursprünglichen lebensstil von zum
beispiel wildtieren gelebt haben davon
gibt es immer weniger
das heißt da war auch oft kontakte wie
gesagt die kontakte haben sich verändert
weil jetzt andere arten gejagt werden
aber was das allerwichtigste ist ist das
ja eben in diese gebiete vordringen die
ökosysteme durcheinander bringen und
zugleich sind die eine enorm große und
kleine population das heißt wir haben
diese menschliche population mit einer
hohen konnektivität früher wenn so ein
virus von irgendeinem haften oder
fledermaus oder was auch immer auch die
menschen übergesprungen ist in einem
urwald dorf im kongobecken dann hat das
dort vielleicht schaden angerichtet was
dramatisch und traurig ist ist von dort
aus aber nicht weitergekommen weil die
leute isoliert war
heutzutage kommt man mit motorrädern mit
autos wirklich inzwischen in die
entlegensten gegenden gegen das heißt
aber auch dass diese krankheitserreger
dort rauskommen und auch die letzten
ebola epidemie
die wir gesehen haben waren wesentlich
größer als die der traditionell kennen
oder an ein zwei drei dörfer betroffen
waren dann wurde das ganze isoliert und
ein gedenkt inzwischen kommt auch dass
wir uns in die großen städte das wurde
ja auch viel gerichtet auch extrem
dramatisch dass die menschliche
population spielten eine ganz ganz
wichtige rolle und die hohe
konnektivität und globalisierung
nun brauchen wir vielleicht gar nicht so
weit zu schauen sondern können uns auch
mal angucken welche auswirkungen unsere
massentierhaltung zb hierzulande hat
dazu gibt es auch verschiedene
kommentare und fragen im chat zum
beispiel schreibt yolanda reimann über
youtubes tut mir leid es ganz viel
youtube heute antibiotika resistenzen
kommen von der massentierhaltung in
europa nun sind antibiotika resistenzen
nochmal ein sonderthema aber wie
schätzen sie das ein welche rolle spielt
unsere art tiere zu halten und zu nutzen
in dieser gesamtgemengelage ich bin
eigentlich ganz froh dass das thema
antibiotika das ist ganz auch
angesprochen wird weil das ist ja auch
regelmäßig übertragung von
verschiedensten salmonellen coli und so
weiter von dem von den nutztieren zu
menschen und dann ist hat die frage wie
bekämpft man die keime in erster hier
steht natürlich die hygienemaßnahmen und
da sind wir in deutschland ziemlich gut
aufgestellt aber was ist wenn da jetzt
auch resistente keim darunter sind und
je mehr unverantwortlich antibiotika
eingesetzt werden in der tierhaltung das
haben wir ein problem in deutschland das
wird viel diskutiert aber wenn sie da
einmal über deutschland hinaus gucken
gerade in die länder wo eben auch die
aufklärung nicht so gut funktioniert und
vielleicht auch die regulierung der
antibiotika dass antibiotika handelt
dann ist das eine der neuen großen
emerging infectious disease das heißt er
neu auftretender infektionskrankheiten
neue multi resistente erreger die auch
zum beispiel aus sozialen afrika und
viele von diesen gebieten gibt wo die
leute es einfach nicht besser wissen sie
denken damit wird meint ihr schneller
stärker größerer vetter und die
konsequenzen gar nicht bedacht also das
ist ein riesenfeld was durchaus im fokus
genommen werden muss nun gibt es wenn
ich das richtig gelesen habe 3000 viren
die von forschern bereits beschrieben
erforscht worden sind aber man geht
davon aus dass es weit mehr als eine
million viren da draußen gibt wie groß
ist denn ihre sorge dass corona gar
nicht
gefährliche virus war das uns heimsucht
sondern dass uns da noch ganz andere
dinge bevorstehen
ja also die frage ist immer so ein
bisschen was ist das gefährlichste was
die leute denken immer so 1 gbo was ein
wirklich ziemlich schnell tötet das dann
noch respiratorischen übertragen das
wäre der supergau das stimmt gar nicht
die wirklich gemeinden sind die die man
mit sich herumträgt andere leute
infiziert ohne es wirklich zu wissen und
dann ein trotzdem oder einstimmt prozent
der bevölkerung an gemacht also nehmen
wir das hiv ist ja wirklich super gemein
das trägt mit sicherungen infiziert
andere bevor man überhaupt weiß und
deswegen kann sich so ein virus auch
extrem gut festgefressen in der
menschlichen population und so ein
bisschen diese eigenschaft hat die stars
koch zweier leider auch mit der milden
symptomatik und der symptomatischen
träger also ich finde das ist schon
relativ nah an einen dieser worst case
wenn sich das jetzt noch irgendein ist
aus denkt dann haben wir echt ein
problem und wir sehen ja dass wir schon
ein problem haben also das heißt über
sehr viel schlimmes finden muss man gar
nicht nachdenken aber und die natur ist
vielfältig es kann sein dass das nächste
problem wiederum anders aussieht also da
muss man
und da muss man auf alles gefasst sein
das was wichtig ist jetzt zu verstehen
was ist die diversität an verschiedenen
viren aber auch bakterien parasiten da
draußen um uns besser vorzubereiten und
zwar das sehen wir ja auch jetzt mit der
impfstoffherstellung das ging relativ
schnell die große diskussion in der
community ist wenn man jetzt gut
verstärken kann
es ist die diversität was ist dieser
wolke an wir sagen wir mal auch zum
beispiel um diesen jahres kauf zweier
kann man auf halde schon mal vor
produzieren nicht bis ganz zum schluss
aber so dass man zeit gewinnt impfstoffe
die mandant schneller einsetzen kann um
dann diese epidemie vorzuschlagen bevor
sie zur familie werden also da gibt es
sehr interessante und vielversprechende
ansätze und zeigt einfach die forschung
ist jetzt nicht nur interessant für
irgendwie die wissenschaftler und
lustige publikationen sondern hat an der
rechten public health also einen
direkten einfluss auf die
gesundheitsschädlichkeit dann schließt
sich quasi der kreis zu beginn unserer
sendung und wir greifen noch mal die
frage nach dem patienten 0 auf der
captain fragt über youtube was bringt es
überhaupt patient null zu finden man
weiß dann zwar woher das virus kommt
allerdings fällt es mir schwer wirklich
realistisch durchführbare konsequenzen
dafür zu finden zu finden
was würden sie sich denn wünschen was
müsste man finden damit man daraus
lernen kann für die zukunft was wäre das
beste forschungsergebnis dieser mission
dass sie sich vorstellen können
ja das beste vorstellung geht es leider
kann uns was hier als
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
die auch wirklich aussuchen was wir dann
schönen ja also es kann ein szenario
sein
das ist so wenig wie hantaviren in
deutschland die irgendwo die man sich
beim ausfegen seiner hütte irgendwie
holt da kann man natürlich den leuten
dann empfehlen zieht einen mund nasen
schutz an und hat man ja kein problem
heutzutage wenn ihr da irgendwas solche
aktivitäten macht dann sei der relativ
gut geschützt vor dem hand harmlos zum
beispiel ja das ist was ganz praktisches
aber wenn es jetzt eben sagen wir mal
das klassische szenario ist fledermaus
und dann übertragen auf irgendein
intensiv wahrscheinlich noch gehalten
das tier gefahren das tier da
irgendwelche katzenartigen oder marder
artigen oder so etwas
das ist natürlich die frage kann man
dann es schaffen das management dieser
fahren wenn sie denn
sein wissen ich bin ja kein großer
freund von aber wenn sie denn ohne sein
wissen was man sagt es muss auf jeden
fall dieser tierhaltung so gestaltet
werden dass es garantiert kann kontakt
zwischen bild tieren also noch frei
herumlaufenden wildtieren und den
intensiv gehaltenen tieren gibt
ähnlich wie bei uns viele dieser
schweineställe zum beispiel und geflügel
stelle ja extrem abgeschottet sind dann
ziehen sie auch quasi so eine voll
schutzmontur an wenn sie daran gehen
damit man eben nichts hinein bringt also
da kann man auch dann bei den
empfehlungen bei dem management von
tierhaltung waffen machen aber es kommen
die ihnen wirklich darauf an was wir
finden und es wird in der community
gespannt beobachtet was sie finden
werden ich kann hier dem chat entnehmen
dass das interesse an ihrer arbeit sehr
sehr groß ist hier fragt zum beispiel
blexen über youtube wo sind die
kommenden forschungsergebnisse von herrn
dr leben und seinem team einsehbar und
auf facebook fragt roxy diamond gibt es
regelmäßige updates der expedition
werden arbeitsergebnisse online
dokumentiert und wenn ja wo ja also ich
den hut bei der ganzen mission hat ja
die die weltgesundheitsorganisation die
bhu auf und die philosophie ist offen
mit der öffentlichkeit darüber zu reden
was läuft und deswegen sieht sich jetzt
auch hier
man kann auch der seehof homepage die
updates sich anschauen da gibt es eine
seite ist nicht extrem leicht zu finden
aber empfindet sie wo zum beispiel die
namen der ganzen team mitglieder zu
finden sind es gibt eine
kurzbeschreibung der expertise und dann
gibt es die sogenannten terms of
reference das ist sozusagen die arbeits
beschreibung für die mission und die ist
dort komplett publiziert und das ist
auch das dokument mit dem ich heute wenn
jetzt die kolleginnen und kolleginnen
aus dem handel zurück sind dann wird es
garantiert einen bericht geben für diese
vision und den kann man dort auch
einsehen
aber ich möchte davor warnen in diesem
bericht werden eher zukünftige
arbeitsfelder definiert werden dann wird
jetzt nicht drin stehen wie genau die
übertragung
nach gefunden hat das ist noch ein
längerer weg ist ja da sind also nicht
die erfahrung die erwartungen zu hoch
schrauben aber wir arbeiten dran und
hoffen dass wir dann ordentliche daten
zur verfügung stellte dann hoffen wir
dass alle mit ihnen sind gespannt auf
die ergebnisse hoffen dass es nicht
allzu lange dauert wobei wir ja in
dieser pandemie gelernt haben dass alles
immer länger dauert als wir uns das
erhofft haben
hd erleben dass vielen herzlichen dank
dass sie heute abend mit gemacht haben
dass sie die fragen der user beantwortet
haben und userinnen und ich wünsche
ihnen noch einen schönen abend und das
wünsche ich ihnen allen zu hause die
mitgemacht und zugeschaut haben auch
jazz bis zum nächsten mal